let me show you the story we got the
story from Fox News
New York Governor refusing to budge on
vaccine minute for nurses you're
replaceable
I don't think they realize right we had
a story that one Hospital in New York
was no longer deliver babies because
they had no maternity ward nurses
this is a bet on this is about the New
York Governor is going to lose they're
not replaceable
not gonna happen you know who is
replaceable the governor oh yeah that's
true you know I could replace the
governor with a golden retriever and
we're probably better off definitely so
when they start
firing people I think the economy is
going to just yeah you look they they
come out and they say we're in a very
serious pandemic we need to mandate this
stuff okay what happens when you
eliminate nurses in the middle of the
pandemic pandemic gets worse that's
where we're going weren't they just
complaining that we're having a nursing
shortage I don't understand what she's
paying they're they're literally paying
travel nurses exorbitant amount of fees
to come work for them when they could
just pay the nurses a little bit more
but know instead are going to go ahead
and fire them yeah what did she say
she'll bring in a foreign staff or
something that's so expensive we're
sending out a call Statewide there are
facilities for example in New York that
98 of the staff are vaccinated they
don't have a worker shortage we are
working closely with these hospitals to
find out where we can get other
individuals to come in and supplement
nursing homes and other facilities her
comments come up she had already said on
Tuesday while visiting the Niagara power
project those who refuse we will find
replacements those who refuse you have
my utmost respect do not give the
government an inch they will take 10
miles it's a power play that's that's
all it is because I mean again if you
have no versus refusing the vaccine
mandate and nurses are regarded as
health professionals then what do you
think is going to happen to the rest of
the people these certainly must be the
stupidest nurses on the planet to be in
these hospitals where they can actually
see the vaccine workings and then reject
them what strange individuals I'm being
facetious by the way the point is I
don't know what they're experiencing and
there are a lot of people who like the
left have been like wow these someone
actually tweeted us on the left they're
like these nurses must be really stupid
to be working in the hospitals where
they can see the vaccines work and
refuse them and it's like
maybe there's still breakthrough cases
maybe there's like it doesn't matter if
you're a nurse and you see people coming
in for covid you're not going to see a
grand Global overview of the numbers
well it all goes back to what do you
define as a breakthrough case because
again I think the vaccines were rated
even at their Peak for like 95 to 90
efficacy so what do you call the other
five percent what do you call the other
10 that's expected so that's not even a
break again that's a semantic fear word
like Breakthrough case ooh your vaccine
it may or may not work no we've already
controlled for that but the fact is you
get the vaccine you have a better chance
of surviving then you can develop real
immunity now the issue with the whole
nurses refusing mandate is if you get if
you get the vaccine you get and you get
the SARS cov2 virus up in your nose you
can still spread it but you don't know
you have it because your symptoms are
reduced so now they can potentially
spread it to even more patients because
they're almost confirmed to be
asymptomatic or especially if they have
a working immune system they're not
going to have symptoms so now
that's controlling for a mistake that
they made because again we just didn't
have the status like I said nobody's an
expert on this you know what I say we do
it right now
I say
not a vaccine mandate a a swab mandate
to enter all establishments so every
business has to have someone employed at
the door and when you walk in they stick
the thing in your nose they put it down
you wait 15 minutes or whatever how long
does that take it takes 15 minutes or no
it takes longer than that doesn't it
yeah I think about 30. all right you
stand outside for 30 minutes and then if
you're you all right you can come in now
I got the finger the finger test where
they prick your blood and they check or
whatever that was negative but they like
put the thing on your finger and they
smash it and then it like goes through
your skin and they do the blood that was
instant it was like you literally look
and go you're good it was like well
instant was more like put the thing on
my forehead and then they like put a
green light on my forehead or something
you guys get that and they're like yeah
yeah trying to see if the laser trying
to see if you're in manifestations of
you know if you're febrile yeah that's
what it's doing for sure the story shows
they don't care about you they don't
care about your rights they don't care
about your freedom they don't care about
the Constitution they will replace you
so we should replace them
we don't need these Fat Cats these
bigwigs it's a it's our duty to replace
them I don't like term limits man term
limits term limits how do we make how do
we make it happen fast we don't need to
make it happen fast how do we make it
happen legitimately midterms yes but
there are two distinct cultures in this
country that I don't think that solves
the problem at all I don't know what
does solve the problem because you can
have uh Tom Cotton come out and say we
should consider whether or not covet
leaked in a lab and New York Times says
crackpot conspiracy theorists you know
Tom Cotton puts out crackpot conspiracy
theory and then a year later some guy
former New York Times like actually it
may be and they go oh it may be or
Hunter Biden's laptop you they come out
and they're like they found an old
laptop there's no proof we're not going
to look at it the NPR said it's not even
news we won't entertain it Twitter said
we're going to block the New York Post
from sharing it and then a year later
they're like oh that lived up thing yeah
that was true yeah this thought that we
used to write constitutions and laws now
we write code so if the code does it
there's no like enforcement the code
happens so I mean like if you're living
in a digital Society the code's going to
dictate what you can and can't do just
by basis of what the code is is coded to
do so it's like the law is built into
society at that point the law is part of
the function so maybe that's in the
future like social media you could you
could use a word on YouTube that makes
your video not appear
so there's like invisible enforcement
that someone put in play that is shaping
our culture without anyone's permission
we've lost without control the machine
is taking over and here's a crazy thing
it's not an AI it's just a random
amalgamate amalgam of different code and
maybe some machine learning but for the
most part
they ban they they ban words based on
what words if a word could sound like
another word and they they'll ban you
for it they ban sounds right there's
literally no oversight and I mean that's
the argument against having just code
because again code's going to happen
there are going to be errors because
code is dealing with people people can
say something a code can't sort out for
sarcasm a code can't sort out whether or
not you're quoting something unless you
say begin quote end quote or something
like that and if you you go that route
and you just eliminate you know let's
say enforcement or politicians in
general where's the appeal process you
could build it into the system like a
jury system uh with like a transparent
free software code and then if there's a
if something feels like they were
wronged by the way the code acted they
could appeal to a jury of your peers
like a thousand random people could get
an opportunity to view the process and
then then that could self-alter the code
if if you get enough times that this
thing has gone wrong then the code
rewrites itself or the people overseeing
the code can rewrite it
sounds sounds good but again if it deals
with people and it's dealing with you
know personal personal interpretations
and then you know that's personal
interpretations are being cultivated by
that same code and algorithm then you
know you're just at back at square one
interesting you know we there's a lot of
problems in that because people are
going to argue and then you're going to
get people saying here's the real
problem and it's going to be it's going
to break down as to who gets to
implement the code I think maybe maybe
one of the simplest solutions would be
if you know
you just took one person and appointed
them Supreme Chancellor with absolute
power to do anything and then just said
you know what you take care of us yeah
we don't have to fight anymore like that
we'll just have them be allowed to do
anything and control all of the law
enforcement and uh just accept that
their decisions are law genius but you
know we we say that jokingly but the
fact that you know the fact I had had a
disclaimer because but no we say that
jokingly but here's the problem the left
is constantly burning books removing
history removing the stories and tales
of when we did things like that and when
they went horribly wrong so what happens
when you get the Next Generation that
does come up with that idea and they
don't have the history to tell them
you you might not want to do that that's
a big part of why I don't like that
they've censored the swastika because
you need to know you've got to know that
there's a Nazi party man you gotta know
there's there's cartoons Family Guy
Justice League that they show these
symbols and now it's like they're like
oh we can't show that it's offensive I'm
just assuming that they ban this one I
don't know if the swastika's banned can
you show a swastika on YouTube uh it is
it is algorithmically reduced in a lot
of capacities and depending on the
context Twitter what might remove it or
put or flag it and there's a big
difference we talked about this before
the show talking about something racy
like uh a word is very different than
using that word to describe someone or
attack someone but it should matter for
of course you know it shouldn't matter
for the future no no it it matters to
human beings it doesn't matter to the
machine yeah the machine doesn't care
why you you know or actually I think it
no longer matters to the people either
it's like that Netflix executive was was
explaining to people racial slurs and
why were banned and what they were and
he got in trouble for saying it imagine
being part part of like diversity and
inclusion thing where you're like we're
going to be explaining racial slurs why
they're offensive and why you can't say
them and then someone gasps when you say
it to tell them not to say it and he got
fired so he gets this Netflix that gets
called to HR and they're like what
happened he goes I was explaining to
them racial slurs and like what was not
acceptable and and I said and they went
he said it again it's like well you
asked him what you got fire lost his job
John Schnatter yeah look at papa John we
had Papa John in the show he was
explaining on a phone call how this
word's offensive and like you know
Colonel Sanders who said nobody even got
mad at him and they were like oh he said
it he didn't call anybody any racial
slurs saying the sound is so different
than calling someone a name I could call
you a really I could be like call you a
name that's like an innocuous word and
it's more offensive than if I'm
discussing the etymology of a word there
was a period where uh people were using
Facebook Skype Twitter as like slurs
trying to get the word banned I guess or
whatever the point was but there was a
period where it was like the left was
writing saying like these are now slang
for racist terms or whatever and it's
like oh geez dude in the in the Kyle
Rittenhouse case apparently the judge
said he didn't recognize the okay symbol
as a symbol of white supremacy and that
he thought it was um what would he say
used it was really funny literally
everyone let me say Michael sailor man
I'm curious I don't remember I've seen
AOC throw up two of them I know so did
Obama hey okay dog whistles I know it's
perfect it means perfect well actually
it could be more of a dog whistle seeing
how the progressive parties basically
you know again who's it a dog whistle
for
and who is hearing the dog whistles is
it a dog we never just saying it's like
we never consider the possibility that
these people could be entirely
subversive they could be virulent bigots
and this could have been like a 10-year
plan to get in under the guise of being
an ally and eventually turn it back or
and turn the country back to the age of
Jim Crow Chef Boyardee oh
oh I haven't had that
for good reason hands of it so yeah the
judge said the okay sign is you also
used as a game and in Old Chef Boyardee
campaign oh yeah I certainly would keep
the door open if you can show that
there's any connection between the
defendant on the day in question in this
organization but as I said before if
this organization Embraces the defendant
after the fact and he's lyonized because
of his behavior that is not something
that the jury can make anything out of
that would be lawful
wow yeah now the question is in again
with algorithms do you get that level of
nuance into it
can algorithm be that nuance and make
that judgment call at this stage I don't
think so I I would hather that it
couldn't it will never unless you get
algorithm that's so sufficient that it
can replace humans entirely what would
happen is okay you make the okay sign on
you know on your mind's video and then
it the AI Flags it and it's like hey
offensive thing and then you're like no
I wasn't doing it offensively I was
doing it in non-offensively so then you
you appeal it and then it goes out to
like a thousand people that get to vote
is he did he use it in context or is the
AI right and then they vote and then the
AI changes itself no no no no that's
ideal and once once again your idea is
is absurd and wrong I'll tell you what
we should do and mine should roll this
out as you're posting there should be a
little circle with like a red light
that's you know flash a little bit and
if you're about to post something
offensive it goes I'm afraid I can't let
you do that Ian you're like I want to
freezing your bloodline hold still I
want to post this meme my friend I can't
let you do that cryo freeze that button
and then robotic arms can come out of
the ceiling and still Ian hold still
it's for your own good he's going to
anesthetize you and take away the will
that you ever had yeah one Andreas has
been talking about neural net and one of
the things they might do with it is for
prisoners violent prisoners rather than
put them in prison put them on a neural
net that like dampens their willpower
digital lobotomy I don't know if that's
ethical but it's a use of the technology
Ethics Committee would never go for that
again that's uh but like I said ethical
to put someone in prison for 20 years
you know it's kind of the argument again
then it's like kind of what do you do
with it when you have an unrepentant you
know these are imperfect and we're
dealing with people people are imperfect
and these problems unfortunately will
never have a perfect neat answer all you
can do is just mitigate harm and
unfortunately you know it goes back to
the pandemic Democrats haven't figured
out that you can't do anything you just
got to mitigate the harm there's no
perfect need but everybody's a coward oh
there's power and regular people and the
people in big cities are terrified
they're like they scream that's what
zooby just tweeted out he was like she's
been traveling the U.S and he was like
man these blue States whatever they're
talking about the big cities he says
there's so much fear and it's really
dampening My Vibe it's messing around my
vibes man I want to go back to Florida
and Texas yeah West Virginia it's like
life is it's weird to see uh going to
the casino they ban masks because it's a
casino and they're like you can't wear
masks but people still do it and they
don't say anything but I'm like it's
kind of weird people are smoking in
there West Virginia man we got freedom
it really is great ladies but yeah
Freedom if you can keep it I guess
freedom is scary though to an
infantilized people and that's the
problem is that again people in our
stage this is why I'm black people I I
know I'm not supposed to do that I'm not
supposed to do that but I'm black peeled
when it comes to you know libertarianism
in general because libertarianism would
work when people were more rugged more
robust more open to risk but now
everybody's so infantilized it's like
the uh the muscle and doge meme and the
little cheese and it's like
it's kind of like you know back in the
day people were all just they would take
risks they would do what they needed to
do nowadays it's like someone called me
a mean word online now if there's
something you don't know you just look
it up that didn't exist before that's it
that's something we have and but I mean
the search for the knowledge like just
doing something more than Google search
like going to your library and grabbing
a book that allowed you to uncover more
but we don't have that now you can just
look something up and you are so spoiled
you have to ask people there's a funny
so much conversation was hey what is can
you answer me wrong there was a there's
a funny comic where it's like it says
then it's like two guys sitting down and
one guy goes hey what year was Abraham
Lincoln assassinated the other one goes
I don't know you want to go to the
library not really okay and the panel
below it's like now hey what year was
Abraham Lincoln assassinated and then he
holds up his phone and what was it 1864.
I don't know
thanks for checking out this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com com timcast IRL
Monday through Friday at 8 pm where you
can leave comments and Super Chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time